لدى العديد من الصيادين المعاصرين قصة سمكة كبيرة ،
لكن في اليابان القديمة ، كانت
أصغر الأسماك هي الصيد الكبير
، تقول إن قناة للقيام ببعض
أنشطة الاتصال ،
تم تسمية فن مدينة تاناه غو على اسم هذا النفق ،
اصطاد واحدة من أصغر الأسماك في
نسمي العالم أنك لا تكون بحجم الطماطم ،
أعلم على الإطلاق أنه لا توجد حصيلة لكلاب ، يجب أن يكون ستوكي
خائفًا من إخفاء تلك المحاولات الجيدة التي
لم تفلت من ذلك ، لا أعرف أنني اعتقدت أليس
كذلك ، لكن من الصعب الحصول على قضبان الصيد الخاصة
هذه  حيث جاء توريو وشوهي في
ماناغوا الشخصية ، أخبرك هذا يا إلهي
لا توجد نصوص تودي جادة لكل هذا
كان الشقيقان يصنعان إيدو
خارج قضبان الصيد على مدار الخمسة عشر عامًا الماضية
على أمل تنفيذ
التقليد الذي كان محظورًا في جيبي
من الواضح أيها المتأنق شديد السُمك يمكنك
تناوله ، إنه أمر جيد ، انظر إلى الزومبي ، كان الأمر
دائمًا لا يجب أن أطبخ أحداً ، لكنني
أقول لا اذهب وأنقذنا غدًا ، لذلك
كان أبي رائعًا ، تاتو ياتي ، أخطأني ، هاه
كونان جاك استاء - أنت اليوم
التقيت كان من هذا
[موسيقى]
يمكن أن يستغرق كل قضيب ما يصل إلى نصف عام
للانتهاء من هذه اللعبة الحماسية للغاية ، لذا
يجب أن تنتقم من  ملحمة
[موسيقى]
su casa y mató al Moody أوه ، آسف جدًا ، بارا
هاسر ديسكو لأماتو الذي
لا داعي له كثيرًا للتلميع بالورنيش على الإطلاق ،
ولا تأكل مونيكا جينا
هؤلاء الأطفال ، لكنهم لا يأكلون عنابرنا ولكن
الأجزاء الداخلية النفسية
[الموسيقى  ]